[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
joey has called me that sunday night and
he's like dawg i love him dog
we're taking oh i call late i got i got
i landed in la and i come in from
philadelphia i've seen it called twice
but i missed his call and i was on a
plane so i was like [ __ ] it so i called
him he goes oh now the superstar calls
dawg you missed it we were taking acid
i couldn't tell you on sunday night he
was like yeah me ari and and eddie bravo
although eddie probably was not taking
acid and i was like i was like what he
goes yeah you missed it man i'll call
you tomorrow
and then and then you look at joey's
like periscope and there's a 6am video
of him [ __ ]
uh smoking weed after he'd been taking
acid the night before and i looked it
was eight hours before his last
periscope wow so like oh he's a [ __ ]
fascinating guy oh i bro i just got
introduced to him recently whenever the
comedy story changed managers you know
yeah and he he they brought him back
probably [ __ ] he's another world bro
he's another world he's inspiring and i
always go after him so it's like i get
to see him every time really he's
inspiring he really is inspiring and he
says whatever the [ __ ] he wants dude he
says stuff about
gays blacks jews [ __ ] he says what
dead people oh there's been a prison you
ever heard my favorite one i don't even
know if he does on stage one of my
favorite things he's ever said ever is
he was talking about
black people and he was like
he just said it very flippantly to me
and he was like dog i asked him what was
prison was like and he goes dog
if you think black people are allowed in
the movies
because i've never been around anybody
that has had that much of a
you know an impairment that wasn't like
you know i had a friend that didn't have
any legs and he didn't do that much and
then
um
i had another lady that i think was just
lazy when i was growing up you know and
she also was taking care of a kid a
black child and both her and her husband
were white and they were pretending like
it was their child to everybody even
though the lady that swept at his school
bus was black miss tilly
and it was obviously her child and we'd
go over there and it was the weirdest
thing like this our son boogie and it
would be like
dude they had him dressed up like a
little cowboy and [ __ ] like to make him
just seem even wider
dude i no joke i remember this little
boogie he'd have on these red boots and
he would do this little [ __ ] dance by
the door when you went in
and it was like what
like even i know that you can't get a
black kid out of two white people no
matter how hard you try i was a fan of
you on road rules yeah i was a re i
thought you should be a comic when i
first saw you on the road do you
remember me telling you that story yeah
or were you telling me your wife thought
i was cute yeah
she definitely thought you were not
offense that i didn't hear what you said
but i mean like you know i was a
22 year old kid i was like ah no um
that's more exciting i wouldn't mind
doing a residency in vegas
really
how does this [ __ ] end though oh not
good we're talking away ralphie's ends
damn little ralphie that's what they
would call it oh my god what if the last
special you did was just like uh ralphie
mae
that was the name of it oh man and you
look just like ralph like you were that
crazy
dude i i
i feel guilty now i mean i know that i
had nothing to do with this but me and
him were on a cruise ship
right before he passed like a few months
before he passed does he sleep in the
middle of a [ __ ] he has to sleep in the
middle of a cruise ship
at 600 pounds or 500 pounds you couldn't
sleep on the side of the cruise ship
could you he's he was sleeping a lot
that trip we all thought we were coming
in to play like a joke thing and then
they like secluded us yeah and they were
like oh this is a contest and then we
realized we're i i wanna i want us i
always jack the number up because i
don't remember but it was like 14 grand
an episode was something ridiculous 7
500 an episode we got which was crazy
money there yeah it was crazy money it
still is it's
good 7 500 episodes not bad money like
no not now and so um and i remember
so i remember donnell was like
donnell and rebecca he was trying to buy
his mom like a new heart or something
wasn't he
i don't think so he's told me he was
really yeah he secretly told me like a
private oh is that the first elimination
when you had to pick someone i think to
try to keep him on he said his mom
needed a new whatever you get from
diabetes when you're black i don't know
what that is that ruined your liver i
think oh [ __ ] but she didn't it was a
lie yeah great lie uh she but yeah you
uh
you won the first challenge and you had
to vote someone off
and you had to pick who went home kyle
cease yeah and you picked kyle cease and
kyle was like he had made hats for every
week
that was one of the hardest i've ever
laughed and it's what i miss about
hanging out with black comics was
[ __ ] breaking balls but do you
remember cops made hats for every week
week one week two week three week four
week five week six week seven
and he had like a bag of hats
and uh
and he was gonna wear him on the show
and do you remember he walked up the
first day and he had his weak one had on
and donald ross goes that's right son
you are the weak one
i [ __ ] that was
the funniest can you believe the talent
that they had on that show whoever cast
that should cast everything this is how
bad i was hurt when leon dumped me
i
i went into my shower because i didn't
want anyone to hear me yeah yeah but i i
couldn't sit on the ground i want to sit
on the ground so i brought one of those
exercise balls in but into the shower
into the shower but it couldn't fit
through the door so i had to deflate it
crying bring it in the shower crying
reinflate it crying and sit on it crying
breathe deep when you're crying too
and so
i'm sitting
on i lived up on it's a street called
glencoe got it right a beautiful man
right above yeah i know exactly where
that is
sitting there eating an asian pear i
hadn't drank in a couple days i was
not out of any other thing that i've
been crying this whole time is this in
the bible i feel like this is in the
bible dude yeah and so uh stewed comes
out lived up there
and he goes uh
what did he do what did he say he goes
what's going on and i was like uh i'm
going through some [ __ ]
and i said something about because he he
he was a how did he get in the shower
and he came in no no no no he was i was
on the street i was on the street on the
i was on the street in the asian pair
okay okay
sorry i merged this up here somewhere
i didn't know we left the apartment
remember you tell us stories and me and
donna will be doubled over and you
didn't understand why they were funny
yeah at the time do you remember the
story about
when you were a kid you were made of
like a
lemonade and vodka you took your dad's
car yeah you went to thomasville but you
got lost so you decided to go home and
you got pulled over oh yeah i pulled her
by the cops and you s
and he the cop
said i don't know he goes where are you
going i was supposed to be i was heading
to a party and we couldn't get there
right yeah and he said where are you
going
and you were never on my
yeah so you said that's like covington
because that's where i'm from yeah and
then he goes where are you coming from
and i said covington
because that's where i left from dude
it was on a storm
but you weren't trying to be funny you
just told
here's the thing once i get a disease
all i got to do
clean my lifestyle up and i then i think
i can deal with it okay two other
diseases you think you could beat
um
hmm
what's something with your eyes
optim um optimization
i could definitely optimize what is that
i think that's just a word this is
getting better yeah yeah um i could beat
the gout easy
yeah gal it's easy that's just shrimp
you know too much shrimp [ __ ] not
enough elbow movement um but it affects
millions across the [ __ ] across the
south
i grew up in the gout belt dude
everybody had gout i really feel like i
grew up in the stray animal belt of
louisiana and they don't really have
this anymore because everybody has pets
now but they had a long time where there
was just i felt like thousands of strays
running around like joey diaz he got bit
by animals i got jumped by a bunch of
cats on my birthday once dude i'm not
even joking dude and one of them i swear
to god
some of them got me on the ground and
one of them came off a [ __ ] rooftop
from next door i swear to god i still
remember
a couple of them were getting me and
looking back and seeing one come from
something in the air
and uh
and they had tons of stray animals where
i was from you couldn't you'd infuse
that in everything you did wherever you
went or if you were gonna bike or play
ball
cats
and that'll make you feel like a little
[ __ ] too i mean first of all your dad's
dying and now there's cats jumping you i
try to learn french wants to get a woman
back
i made a boat out of clay for a woman
once i made a mixed date for liam you
did dude she dumped me she dumped me
devin and i went fishing one time
somebody would go get like lunch meat or
whatever and go fish right yeah well one
time these bull these white kids are
walking across this
literally these standby mirrors are
going over this brit this train track
over this water where we're fishing down
by the river and they start throwing
rocks at us and calling us the n-word
yeah
and i'm trying to yell to them i'm not
the n-word
guys
guys are you colorblind just one of us
i'll back off
and devin my buddy devin is dying that
i'm trying to like because i'm also i
think i'm mildly doing it to entertain
him you know yeah so it was but at the
same time dodging rocks from these
racist kids who obviously have poor
eyesight you know
when i was a kid i thought jacking off
meant you were gay like i didn't know
that that meant that you just were a
regular person right and so i lived with
that until i was like until i was 18
years old you were jerking off thinking
you were gay i thought i just thought i
must be gay i can't stop i must be one
of those weird gay guys that's only
attracted to women because i don't i'm
only jacking off the chicks and i'm
hooking up with chicks i had sex with a
chick but i can't quit jacking off and
then we got into our fraternity and they
said something about jacking off and i
was like hold on you guys you guys do
that and they're like everyone does it
and i was like where the [ __ ] was this
open in honesty like where was this my
whole entire [ __ ] life and they call
it jacking off with the word like a name
jack no that's when they started calling
it rubbing one out oh everyone rubs one
out yeah and i was like rub was one out
they're like yeah you know
and i was like
dude eddie bravo said they people would
just used to say play with themselves
yeah and it was totally normal what you
gonna what's going on today man i'm
probably gonna just you know have you
know have some cool lady maybe play with
myself or maybe you know get a new harp
or something joe's like that with
putting out two podcasts three podcasts
a week he does that many a week joe's
[ __ ] man joe's got this game locked
down how's he to talk to his uh
he just started kind of like will give
me a little bit more face time you know
he's great he's great you see he doesn't
believe in jesus christ does he i don't
think so
yeah
but that's fine
you know
i don't think he does yeah he might not
believe in jesus christ but
i mean i think he believes and i'm
drinking out of his mug right here look
i believe i think he believes in a
higher power i mean he's done dmt so
he's spoken to the aliens really i mean
i guess ultimately i'm just in the
[ __ ] game i mean i'm locked in yeah
you know and it's so scary chatted up in
prison that's yeah dude you're like
[ __ ] posting them you're like nabisco
malone i wouldn't mind
and that was a post nabisco joke a lot
of people won't get that that was good
thanks man um
i thought she hated me and i got naked
with her in the tub
you got naked in the tub too it was me
you and red remember that [ __ ]
yes you do we we were up for elimination
me no no we had gotten granted immunity
on the banana oh yeah yeah talk about
racist they have pictures of you
lunell's face open mouth and we had to
put bananas in it [ __ ] bananas in it
like it had her looking like and we were
just shoving bananas down her throat and
we got immunity and our prize was we got
to take a bath with the nell yes and i
remember lunell was like grabbing all
around yeah
i'll take my [ __ ] pants off and i
took my pants off she took her panties
off and we're all in the tub and i
remember the president of comedy central
at the time lauren lauren correa lauren
carrajo yeah that was her who was was
laura laura yeah i can't remember correa
was right she was waiting out she was
watching
like in video village and i'm naked
pressing my dick against the shower
window and she's like we can't use any
of this
tulane university had their primate
testing facility in our town that's
where most people worked at right
so
and in 1994 like 70 infected monkeys got
out in our town and they literally the
police came to ymca summer camp and let
the oldest kids leave to help them look
for these monkeys right are you serious
yeah and i remember like like guys they
had guys with like rebel flags in their
truck i'm like it's not a racial thing
guys this is these are [ __ ] 70 these
are chimpanzees and macaws that are
loose around town you know this isn't a
gang that's moved in you know uh but i
remember me and a couple of other kids i
still remember having a wet bathing suit
on
cornering a [ __ ] chimpanzee outside
of a kenny rogers roasters with a police
officer
and three other kids like
you know by this drive-through and this
[ __ ] fat
elf of a woman honking at us like we're
ruining her you know dream shake she's
buying or whatever and her [ __ ]
cornbread what we're trying to [ __ ]
save our town from a [ __ ] who knows
what this monkey had from a family
yellow planet of the apes apocalypse
yeah maybe something walter reed missed
could have been yellow fever i was doing
a college show somewhere this is like 10
years ago
and afterwards i was drinking at a house
on i was drinking at a house right yeah
i didn't know the house was on campus
but the police show up and they say this
house is technically on campus it didn't
look like it was on campus at all it's
like a regular house yeah it's like a
dormitory or like a you know um a
quadruplex or anything like that um
[Music]
so the cops came took me to jail right
and there was this girl i was flirting
with and i was like excited maybe i get
to hook up well anyway i get back to the
hotel where my buddies are staying in
the morning the girl slept over she
hooked up with my buddy right yeah and
um
and he had broken both of us he had two
broken arms though
so my other buddy had to hold him up
while he was [ __ ] her like he like
he like laid on got on top of her but
then my other body was real strong like
adonis like leaned over and just held
him up the whole time by his chest so he
could just like dangle his arms like
because my buddy was on top like he
could just dangle his arms and still
have sex
and then me and the girl ended up having
sex dude and she had the darkest bush
i've ever seen in my life
and it was like three or four inches
long and it was straight she was like
black she was african-american but just
kind of in the [ __ ]
and it was um
just the hair was just very you know it
was more of african type of hair you
know and it was just so exciting it was
such an exciting time i just tell the
story about this kid corki gaines who's
on twitter now his name's it's
cork gaines but he was one of those kids
like you always got one of those kids in
life who maybe just doesn't see
the big picture of things i remember and
there's one stories i saw was him
rolling in dog [ __ ] when we were playing
uh smear the queer yeah oh smear the
queer was the only game in town that was
only game you throw the ball for those
of you that are grew up in political
correctness i don't know what you called
it but that's what we called it when we
were kids and i'm talking about i only
probably called it that for just when i
was a kid
in second grade up to like fourth grade
you'd throw the ball in the air whoever
caught it was the queer and everyone
tried to attack him
and so gorky gaines got the ball and
we're all our friend all my friends in
that and corki lived around the corner
but all the kids on my street were all
like fourth grade fifth grade kids and
they tackled me rolling dog [ __ ] which
no one does anymore no one rolls in dog
[ __ ] no not anymore it just doesn't
happen because everyone picks it up
and it turned white and then it went to
heaven yeah and corky gaines rolled on
his neck and he was like what is it
it was like it was like an apocalypse
movie everyone went inside like shut
their doors lock their blinds and he was
like walking down the center of the
street like he had a bomb around him
help
but uh
oh my god corgi gaines had this um i
remember once my mom used to drive him
home if you call my sister right now and
go what if
if you say quirky games she'll go oh you
smell like bologna that's like just
immediately oh i've dated a numerous
women actually over the years whose
breath smells like different kinds of
meat yeah i dated a chick you smell like
baloney like the first night i was like
she must have had a bloating sandwich
i'll give her i'll give her a pass and
then the next time i was like maybe
she's just in a bologna maybe that's her
[ __ ] lunch and then i spent the night
at her house one night we woke up in the
morning what do you want to do for lunch
i was like [ __ ] it i'll take a baloney
sandwich she's like i don't have bologna
you did that thing where you guys all
walked from on that on that that balance
beam from arabia the first thing i ever
did on there when the kid was freaking
out that one kid who's like the
all-american kid yeah kind of
and he was like guys seriously i'm
really nervous no one make any jokes and
they were like what was his name james
they're like james you're up next and
you went dead man
well i honestly thought he was gonna die
he was bow legged two in only one leg
interesting he only had one leg no he
had two legs but one of his legs was a
bow leg
which is very rare yeah corky games like
i guess there was these i want to say
there were these asian people lived next
door to him oh and he was like they're
gone
but uh but they got a pool we go
swimming in the pool so get your bathing
suit on and come over right after school
so we were like real close like maybe
right around the corner like
and so
i get on my speedo get a towel i go over
to his house meet him and sing we walk
out his front door and i remember it was
like his front door is here
their
fence was like right here so we walked
over the fence and he was like i'll go
check to see if it's safe so he like
opens their fence and then goes around
in and i'm sitting there and the fence
is slightly open also the fence flies
open and he's like dawg
he a huge doberman pincher comes flying
after him and i remember i [ __ ] saw
my life flash for my eyes i was like
this is how i die and the dog just ran
past me and kept chasing me just kept
running and i was like i was like
what am i like you know weird i was like
do i just go home now
and i was like i'm not going to chase
him i was like [ __ ] i'm going and i just
walked home and then sat on my couch
with my towel still over my shoulder my
mom's like i thought you're going
swimming and i was like no
she was like what are you gonna do i was
like um give me a second i think i have
ptsd
but those [ __ ] people don't get a
traumatic stress disorder
[Music]
[Music]
foreign